із цього лісу до кордону України з
Росією менш ніж 15 кілометрів тут
постійно небезпека артилерійських
обстрілів А тепер ситуацію додатково
ускладнює зима пересуватися взимку стає
важче бо всі рухи стають одразу
помітними їм може будь-якої миті
прилетіти від ворога зима так дійсно
вона в нас певні корективи в нашу
діяльність в першу чергу це маскування
це рух по заболоченій місцевості по
полях звичайно більше
перебиватися ми мусимо як ми так і вони
це по дорогах або якщо вже там буде
засніжені
замерзші поля то тільки тоді тому що
наступати чи оборонятися
От коли
слякоть грязь Це набагато важче Юрій на
війні з 2014 року а під час
повномасштабного вторгнення він пройшов
Ізюм і Слов'янськ тому не боїться ні
обстрілів ні морозів Я прийшов 14-15 під
Донецьком було 23-25 тут люди кажуть
буває і до 32 нічого пережили все
нормально на думку військового зима може
сповільнити динаміку бойових дій
Мені здається що з приходом з зими А
головне що мабуть те що і вони вже
більше навчилися і ми багато навчилися
багато краще розуміти організація
взаємодія бойових дій
то фронт Скоріш все з моєї точки зору
більш стабілізується і стане стабільний
температура у цій місцевості вже
опустилася до нуля солдати гріються в
Хижі посеред лісу топлять пічку і
готуються зимувати на фронті зараз майже
її не розтаплюємо там дві два поле на де
і все так більше дров
Хай даже буде мінус 40 каже будуть
пристосовуватися і знаходити рішення як
зігрітися саме головне щоб техніка
працювала прогрівати вчасно щоб були
жидкостя спеціальна так специфіка яка
різниця що зимою що літом стріляти
обслуговування техніки от в чому ця
специфіка зимньої війни і все
ходять погрітися і до цього будинку в
сусідньому селі військові кажуть що він
належить колаборантам цьому будинку
особисто то жили любителі Русского Мира
ті які зустрічали окупантів з хлібом
сіллю ті які
здавали місцевих здавали сімей у яких
наприклад військовослужбовці їхні Родичі
які в Збройних Силах України
за зраду отримували гроші від окупантів
коли наші війська сюди увійшли 11 числа
наче хлопці піхота зайшла в Це село то
вони корову підніж і 13 числа і їх уже
не було забрали що тільки можна дехто
каже що вони поїхали на Харків дехто
каже що на Росії Я не знаю ну в усякому
випадку вони зараз сюди повертаються
бояться що бояться нашої правосуддя тому
що все-таки це зарадники зрадники
власних Батьківщини
солдати зміцнюють старі радянські танки
уламками трофейної російської техніки
маскуватися листям більше не вийде
Це звичайно не така зима але вночі в нас
доходило до мінус 70 градусів і знаєте
Ну
де така вже і проблема ніби воно
звикається воно поступово поступово
звикається звісно коли ти там по коліна
постійно в болоті ноги мокрі це не так
приємно треба знову ж таки треба частіше
ходити грітися проте воно звикається і є
Напевно якась мотивація для того ти
розумієш чому ти це робиш і відповідно
воно якось додатково зігріває тобі душу
і це заспокоює і де є сили наступні бої
Сергій вважає що попри значно складніші
умови введення бою взимку це навряд чи
зменшить запал військових ЗСУ відвоювати
українській території Звичайно що зараз
воювати буде Значно важче хлопцям ну
всім холодніше стає і перерви напевно
Потрібно десь бігти зігріватися Не
завжди є така можливість проте
все одно Я думаю що інтенсивність не
спадає вона буде така сама А можливо і
навпаки наростати тому що підозрюю що
нам потрібно зараз Чим швидше відбивати
свої території і тому нема дуже часу на
пауза Звичайно що важче стає проте
потрібно йти вперед хто тішиться снігу
то це діти В сусідньому селі
Взимку ми любимо
займатися ліпити сніговика кататися на
горках кидатися сніжками
кататися на санках
школа зачинена вже кілька місяців
навчання дистанційне та й з електрикою
проблеми як ми заселялися то тут
електрики не було днів 10 да більше до
Місяця не було електрики от вона
появилася і тоді як ідуть масові ракетні
удари по Україні по інфраструктурі то і
в нас не стає електрики ось два дні
напередодні цього не було тільки
сьогодні появилось світло у селі ще досі
не відновили газопостачання але солдати
мають свої балони з газом і похідні
плитки найближчими днями температура
опуститься ще нижче та військові
налаштовані рішуче і щодо морозів і щодо
війни на фронті ми їх тут завжди готові
зустріти тут в нас військ досить люди
навчені Головне що ми праві всі
мотивовані всі воюють нікого не треба
так як у них
брати там з тюлем чи ще якимось чином
іммігрантів там таджиків чи узбеків
залучати на всі самі йдуть самі
розуміють що це їхня Домівка і їхня
держава і всі мотивовані
[музика]